I'm Katie and I work at light Dash which
is an open source bi tool and today I'm
going to be talking a bit about why I
think data products are not just for
data teams
so in 2022 Tableau commissioned
Forrester Consulting and run this big
survey across I think 2 000
organizations where they ask these
organizations about data literacy at
their companies and they found that
organizations that actually invested in
data literacy and education found
increases in productivity and Innovation
and customer and employee experiences
and they found that 82 percent of the
leaders expected all employees to have
basic data literacy and 70 of employees
were expected to heavily use data by
2025 which was up by 40 in 2018.
and all of this is kind of just
reinforcing the fact that data isn't
just for data teams anymore so we have
this huge growing population of data
literate people and they're going to
want their answers to be based off of
data so when it comes to talking about
people in a company that are actually
using data we now have these two
personas the data team which we've
always had but then there's the rest of
the company or business users or data
consumers as I like to call them and so
as the people building the products for
these data tools uh we have to be asking
ourselves how are we actually Building
Products that serve both of these users
not just data teams anymore but also
these people that are really data
illiterate and wanting to build data
tools as well or use data tools as well
um so I think that data products are not
just for data teams anymore and I think
that we need to be building products
that can be used by data teams but also
by the rest of the company and for the
rest of my time here I'm going to be
talking about how we can actually use
design principles to help us with
building products for multiple personas
um and for those of you who haven't
heard of design principles before or
aren't that familiar with them they're
basically values that kind of act as
like a compass when you're building your
product so they can be really helpful in
simplifying really complex business
decisions or product decisions they can
guide you to asking the right questions
when you're building products and for
multiple personas here it becomes a bit
more complicated
um and so the three design principles
that I'm going to talk about are
flexibility and usability forgiveness
and familiarity
and I'm going to talk about all of these
through the lens of building a bi tool
because conveniently I'm building a bi
tool so I know a bit about it but also
when we think about kind of tools that
oh
uh when we think about tools that
interface uh the data team and the rest
of the business a bi tool is a really
obvious one right it's where the data
team shares a lot of their insights and
it's where the data consumers consume
most if not all of their Data Insights
so if we build an amazing bi tool for
the data team that everyone else hates
then we've built a terrible bi tool so
we really need to make sure that we're
building for these multiple personas
um yeah so the first design principle I
want to talk about is flexibility versus
usability and a real life example of
this is installing software on your
machine so if you have a Linux computer
you'll be familiar with something in the
top left and a Mac with something in the
bottom right now my brother is a
software engineer he's like someone
who's like a purist and codes in vim and
like loves configurability so Linux is
an amazing way of like the the
experience of installing software on a
Linux machine is great it's super
flexible it's really configurable it
kind of lets him do exactly what he
wants
um my flatmate is a skiing instructor so
he doesn't know what the terminal is and
he just wants like get things on his
computer like viruses and all like he's
just like get it in there I don't want
to do anything else uh so something like
the Mac uh the max approach to
installing software is definitely built
more for him it's like very usable few
steps to get to your uh end goal and so
this is a great example of flex ability
and usability
now the thing about flexibility and
usability is it's a trade-off right so
if you increase flexibility then you
decrease usability and we want to be
really considerate of this when we're
building products for multiple personas
so that we're really conscious of what
the goal is or the tasks that we're
trying to accomplish when we're building
the product are we focusing on
flexibility or usability and how can we
do that so the ux tactic that we can use
here is we can ask the question what are
our users goals for this product or this
task
and if you have users that want
customization and control then they want
flexibility right if you want to make
the least amount of decisions to
accomplish a goal they want a really
usable product and you can have a heavy
mix of both of these and a great way of
handling that is by actually creating a
visual difference so that users can see
the two experiences and pick the one
that they want
um
now in bi we interact with charts in bi
a lot and so we went and we made sure
that we asked our users what is your
goal when you open a chart to both
business users and kind of the data team
when you ask business users normally
their goal is I really want to just get
in and out right like I want to see the
chart I want to see the data understand
what's going on and then like out of
there into Excel as fast as possible
um but when you talk to the data team
they tend to say I'm using a chart to
build another chart it's like the chart
is a building block to really the next
chart which is where they'll customize
it or kind of dig deeper into something
so here we had a mix of two user goals
one was very much usability which is uh
the business users Focus they want to
get in and out fewest steps possible to
get to their task completion whereas the
data team was much more focused on
flexibility and customization and so the
way that we dealt with this was kind of
going back to the last slide where we
give a visual option where people can
pick the different does that they want
to go down for a flexible versus usable
experience so when you open a chart you
open it in this View mode here which is
really minimal really usable kind of
varied not distracting but then if you
click explore from here or you click
edit then you open a chart in edit mode
which is much more customizable and kind
of fit for the data teams goals when
interacting with charts
um so yeah that's kind of like a great
example or a classic example of building
a flexible versus usable product and
making sure you're identifying your
users goals and building for them
and so the next design principle is
forgiveness uh this is a really good
example of this is turning off your
phone right uh normally turning off your
phone is a two-step operation you have
to push a button and then swipe
something uh and this is because turning
off your phone is like a critical error
right if you turn off your phone it
doesn't phone anymore so uh you don't
really want to be like doing it by
accident
um so the way that they've built in
forgiveness into the product is you
don't do it by accident like you have to
really be like I don't know moving your
butt in a funny way to like accidentally
turn off your phone
um
and so forgiveness is really important
when we're thinking about building data
products and the way that we can do this
is we can ask our users what is the
worst thing that you think can happen
here and we need to make sure that we're
talking to both sets of users right
about their scariest consequences
because they can be different and then
once you find out those consequences we
want to make sure it's really unlikely
to happen so there's a couple of ways
you can do this you can use established
uh usability patterns like red buttons
are bad or you can add previews of
changes or you can also add
confirmations and warnings when they're
doing kind of a critical task
and when you're onboarding users into a
bi tool the most common uh scary thing
for business users is oh my God I don't
want to break something and then for
data team it's like oh my God I don't
want people to break my stuff
um so you have like really two clear
consequences and we wanted to make sure
that when it came to like exploring save
chart that we were kind of avoiding
these consequences for both users so
this is what you see when you open a
chart and what button are you probably
going to press well the giant blue one
right
um so we used established uh usability
palette patterns here to make sure that
we were minimizing the consequence for
users and the big blue button leads you
to a really safe place where you're not
actually editing a save chart and you're
making sure that delete and edit are
hidden behind that gray button so you
have to like really explicitly wanting
to be do those actions wanting to be
doing those actions
um yeah so this is an example of
building forgiveness into your product
and minimizing kind of the worst
consequences for your users
and the last design principle we have is
familiarity and this one I kind of love
this one I find this one's the most
interesting
um there are design patterns that have
been established in almost every product
we use and it's kind of cool when you
think about them so here if I show you a
bunch of web app and mobile
um headers banners and I ask you where
is the menu you'll be like oh that
three-line thing
uh we didn't get taught that in like
school I don't know about you I didn't
get like hamburger icon lessons but we
just like know that that's where the
menu icon is and that's because it's a
really familiar design pattern and the
amazing thing about familiar design
patterns is that they really reduce uh
the learning curve for a product so they
increase also the speed at which a task
is completed and that means you're
ultimately like increasing user
retention and who doesn't want that so
building familiarity into your product
can be really helpful especially when
you're building for multiple personas
and the ux tactic here is to ask the
question is there a familiar experience
for both of our personas that we can use
here so it's really important to do
competitor research to for both of your
user personas to understand if there are
any products
um that they're both using that you can
build familiar experiences into
you can use basic established usability
patterns like we've already talked about
and you can also kind of get an actual
prototype and get people to use it like
can they guess what it does when you ask
them to do the task can they complete it
successfully and is it a familiar
experience to them
now when it comes to data and building a
bi tool one of the most important tasks
is being able to dig into the data
further right like from Day Zero we want
people to be able to do this with little
to no effort so we made sure that we
um did kind of we wanted to build a
familiar process for both the data teams
and the business users here so we did
some user research we did some
competitor research and what we found is
that the most intuitive and kind of
familiar and frequent way of interacting
with data was clicking on it
um and so once we knew that we were like
okay well we want to build it so that
people can click on stuff to interact
with it and we wanted to make sure that
clicking was really intuitive so things
that are clickable look clickable they
either change color or the pointer
changes or you know it gets grayed out
or something and what this meant was
that a really important task in our bi
tool which was interacting with data was
super familiar and easy to kind of get
on board with from day Zero row
and yeah those are three design
principles of flexibility and usability
forgiveness and familiarity that can
help us with building for multiple
personas but why should we care like why
make sure there's like this data
literate population but like why do we
actually care about building for them
and I think that the increase in data
literacy is going to be limited by data
tools unless we start actually changing
how we build them
and what I mean by that is unless we
start building tools for this data
literate population that isn't the data
team we're going to be the reason why
there's not an increase in data literacy
um so that means like thinking about
those business users preferred ux do do
they actually want to be in bi tools
should we actually just like have native
Integrations in their favorite things
like slack and notion
um or do they want to like use natural
querying language for data do they just
don't kind of care about SQL and we need
to make it more approachable for them
and I think once they actually get into
those tools and get access to that data
we need to help them in making using
data to make decisions right so we need
to increase uh and standardize the
context and data tools we need to
improve like the metadata for them
um so that they're more confident in
self-service when it comes to data
decisions and otherwise like I said I
think that as the people building these
data tools ultimately we're going to
become the limiting factor and how much
we can actually increase data literacy
um and the way that we can avoid this is
by building data tools with both of
these personas in mind so we can use
design principles to help us with making
these decisions and there's a lot more
design principles out there but really
the idea is to consider these people
when we're building design tools
uh and that's everything thanks so much
for listening
[Music]